Christine Costner wants her estranged
husband Kevin Costner to show her the
money in new Court docs obtained by E.T
Christine claims the actors proposed
monthly child support payment of 51 940
is not enough to cover her and their
children's expenses you know I don't
like drama in my own life personally
some people seem to thrive on drama I
don't really like it the former couple
who tied the knot back in 2004 shares
three children sixteen-year-old Kaden 14
year old Hayes and 13 year old Grace
your hands on Dad yeah you know we both
driving to school in the morning this
morning we're both in the car we'd get
their packs on away they go Christine
filed for divorce from the Yellowstone
star back in May and the following month
she requested
248 thousand dollars a month in child
support which Kevin calls inflated and
grossly inaccurate instead offering
fifty one thousand nine hundred and
forty dollars per month Christine claims
that Kevin's offer is only 24 percent of
the guideline and only 2.4 percent of
his monthly cash flow Christine points
out that Kevin lists his own monthly
expenses as 240 thousand dollars when
the kids are with him nearly five times
what he's offering her the Court docs
put it bluntly according to Christine
quote he apparently expects his children
to live far below his economic
circumstances when they are with their
mother Christine adds that the biggest
factor in her child support request is
finding housing where the children can
maintain proximity to their father
schools and friends and that proposed 51
940 Christine says it's not going to cut
it she says rent won't be her only
housing cost she'll have to pay
utilities install a security system
purchase Furniture outfit a kitchen and
get Recreational Equipment for their
kids on top of that Christine notes that
she and Kevin have a team of people who
help them maintain the house including
an assistant and chefs we're not shy at
all about running our Ranch
ET got an inside look at Kevin and
Christine's lifestyle when they invited
us to their Aspen Ranch where they tied
the knot back in 2004. we needed to get
her to the spot back in January it was
announced the 160 acre estate was
available to rent
I've never seen it from here
hey look it looks like a field
oh my goodness the Field of Dreams eh
yeah yeah without the corn without the
corn in here it's pretty corny
Flash Forward to present day Christine
is also asking Kevin to cover 100 of the
kids health care private schooling and
extracurricular activities as well as
350 000 in attorney's fees and an
additional 150 000 in forensic costs as
for Kevin's claim that he can't afford
it Christine says that is simply not
credible Kevin's value as an actor has
never been higher especially after the
success of Yellowstone
[Music]
hi John Dudley who solemnly swear
to uphold the constitution of the state
of Montana I'll go till it it doesn't
feel like
um we're interesting I have other things
that I will want to do of course back in
May E.T confirmed Kevin is not returning
to the hit show after season five now
he's set to direct and star in a
four-film civil war series titled
Horizon and American Saga Christine
claims he could have continued on
Yellowstone but chose not to in order to
pursue the new project she's asking that
the first child support payment be made
by July 14th given that she's been
ordered to vacate their home by July
31st
[Music]